from nick hey michael me again
oh nick oh my god yes i remember you
nick thanks for the advice last week on
the
yeah here it is thanks for the advice on
the astrology chicks i'm no longer
seeing any of those women
who collect crystals and whose
apartments smell like a party city on
halloween
however by eliminating those others i'm
now
with a woman i'm glad you've narrowed it
down to one
with a separate potential issue i knew
that when we started dating she was bi
and i thought that it could be fun
because liking hot women is a common
ground
that we share but now i'm wondering if
it will become an issue if we get more
serious
sincerely is two company and three a
crowd
nick you you live an interesting life my
friend you know i suspect it's not
all that different from the lives of
many millennials in gen zeirs but
the fact that this woman that you have
started dating
has had some interesting desires or
perhaps experiences in her life
is not disqualifying in itself that's
true of everybody
um and i suppose that is common ground
liking hot women would be something you
have in common with her
however in your life right now
dating this woman three is a crowd
you know a lot of my friends are libs
and they're little
some of them are pretty radical out
there and i do know people
who have been involved in all sorts of
crazy
relationships with more than two people
and all that sort of stuff
it doesn't work out it does not i've
i've never
seen it work out certainly not before
they stopped doing all that sort of
stuff
uh do not do it this girl sounds
eccentric and interesting and she should
be enough for you and you should be
enough for her
frankly if you're not then tell her to
go take a walk
hey i'm glad you liked that video
there's a whole show though there's a
whole
episode that you could watch here on
youtube subscribe ring the bell you'll
get the notifications or
on apple podcast spotify google play
stitcher google mail
aim zanga live chat i don't know it's
all over the place
the michael knowles show subscribe leave
a five star review we'll see you
[Music]
[Music]
there